hi there everyone you might remember
awhile ago we made a video about a new
world record prime number
millions of digits long Matt Parker even
printed it out for us and it didn't take
just one volume
it took three volumes I've still got it
here lots and lots of digits the
typeface is tiny and it's page after
page you have to pay age of digits now
here's a question how many times does
the number 7 appear in this prime number
let's okay let's go to page 1 line 1 the
5th digit is a 7 and there are many many
more on the first line and many many
more on every line after that in fact
there are well over 2 million 7s in this
prime number it's not surprising there
are a lot of digits now when numbers get
this big Prime's become will they become
pretty sparse so here's another question
is there a prime number bigger than this
one so taking more pages more digits
that has no sevens in it it's almost
unthinkable isn't it that you could have
a number bigger than this that's also
prime that has no sevens in it but you
know what the answer is it's not only
yes the answer is there are an infinite
number of prime numbers bigger than this
one that contain no sevens this has been
proven it was proven by a mathematician
called James Maynard at Oxford
University and we're about to speak to
him now
we're talking about your favorite
subject primes yes okay so today we're
thinking about the digits of prime
numbers and in play are there infinitely
many prime numbers with no sevens
anywhere in their digits or is it the
case that there's only finitely many
Prime's that have no sevens anywhere in
their digits so this might sound like a
pretty easy question
lots of prime numbers that we used to
have no difference in their digits so 13
has no sevens and digits 23 has no
sevens and the digits and when we're
looking at small numbers lots and lots
of small numbers have no sevens in their
digits but when you're talking about
infinitely many numbers you have to talk
about really big numbers and the vast
vast majority of really big numbers have
lots and lots of sentence in their
digits and so you're really looking at
only a very small set of numbers that
have no sevens so one way to measure how
big a set is is to think about summing
one over the numbers so for example you
could choose the prime numbers it's a
famous result that if you sum up 1 over
3 plus 1 over 7 plus 1 over 11 and so on
the this diverges and say becomes bigger
and bigger and bigger so in one way this
is saying that there's quite a lot of
prime numbers even though they're quite
a sparse set in their whole numbers but
if I sum up 1 over N for n having no
sevens in this decimal expansion then
this total sum is less than 100 by this
metric is actually quite a small set of
numbers and smaller than the set of the
times so you might think of Prime's is
quite rare and difficult to find whereas
numbers with no sevens anywhere in their
decimal expansion has been quite easy to
find we see them all the time but
actually when you get to really big
numbers the primes are much much more
common than the numbers with no sevens
in their decimal expansion and it's
always a big problem for people like me
who like to study the times as to kind
of work out if there's infinitely many
Prime's in these different odd sets
which are small subsets of the numbers
we all know there are an infinite number
of prime
but you're saying do we get to a point
where the prime numbers become so big
and with so many digits it's impossible
to ever find one without seven again
yeah so is it the case that every large
enough prime number always has at least
one seven somewhere in this decimal
expansion you'd certainly expect that
most part numbers they were really big
would have lots of sevens in their
decimal expansion maybe it could be the
case that you can never get ones that
are only made up of the digits one two
three four five six eight nine zero one
step bigger than a gazillion or
something like that similarly you can
ask the same thing are there infinite
many Prime's that have no zeros in their
decimal expansion of infinitely many
times have no one's in their decimal
expansion all the problems are pretty
similar to one another and similarly
regardless of whether it's no sevens or
no zeros or no ones we know that the sum
of the reciprocals of those numbers is
always bounded by a hundred again and so
again it's always a fairly small set and
so you expect all really large numbers
or most really large numbers to have
lots of 7s and lots of ones and lots of
zeros and the decimal expansion and
James you cracked this nut right yeah so
I show you that there are indeed
infinitely many Prime's that have no
sevens anywhere in their decimal
expansion and again instead of seven you
can substitute two or three or whatever
number you like regardless how far you
go along the number line so you can go
some huge where long and you choose your
favorite point and then certainly
somewhere beyond there there's going to
be some time which has no sevens and
then another rhyme which has very threes
and so on because they're an infinite
number of primes this fear was
intuitively correct doesn't you know
because there's always another number
did it feel intuitively correct to you
before you proved it
even though in this sense the number of
numbers with no sevens is quite small
it's not so small that you would think
it's that bizarre that you'd be able to
find x the difficult is always showing
it the primes are really difficult to
get your hands on and so the question is
always can I understand the primes well
enough to be able to find
than in these somewhat strange small
sets of integers so if there are an
infinite number of numbers with no
sevens proven well done yeah well done
are there an infinite number of primes
with no sevens or threes can I can I
have two numbers that are missing from
my prime so this is an open problem we
don't know this at all however we would
certainly expect that it should be
infinitely many times with no seconds or
threes you have to be a bit careful
about how far you go along because you
can't have times that have no ones twos
threes fours five six seven or nine
screws then they'd only be made out of
zeros or you can't have phones they've
just made out of twos for example so
there's infinitely many numbers that are
just made out of twos but all of them
are even so you're certainly not going
to get any finds in there other than -
other than - good point you caught me
and it's a quite a famous problem
actually are there infinitely many
Prime's that are just the number one
repeated so you certainly can't have it
when you have a number of digits which
is a multiple of three because you know
that if the sum of the digits adds up to
a multiple of three then and the number
itself is a multiple of three and so it
can't be a fine nonetheless you think
that you would have guessed that there
should be a infinite number of primes
that are just only made up of the digit
one but this would be false for the
digit two but the only candidates would
be one seven maybe like like it can't be
an even because it can't be all twos
fours sixes or eights can't be zeros
character threes can't be nines because
that would ever know like even be module
three could it be all sevens all seven
sounds good to me
yeah so one's and sevens are the only
candidates for mmm what's that called
mono digit I think they're called rap
unit maybe that's it yeah yeah so rep
unit primes so I think ones and sevens
are the only possibilities for that oh
you totally have to get onto that one
okay so that one feels a lot harder that
somehow just missing one digit in base
10 is right at the limit of the current
techniques and even just missing two
digits even though
should clearly be possible already feels
quite a long way beyond all the
techniques that we know at the moment
because these sets get smaller and
smaller and smaller too you look at
bigger and bigger numbers when I heard
that you'd proven this this digit thing
you know about a missing digit I thought
maybe there would be an exception like
two or four that they all fall into it
whether they're even or odd or yeah so
there's a few scientists the last digit
of a prime number is restricted so you
know that the last digit of a prime
number certainly can't be an even number
it can't be a five and so this changes
slightly how many Prime's you'd expect
there to be that have no sevens or no
twos you'd expect there to be slightly
different numbers because of this last
digit phenomenon and similarly there are
some other constraints say to do with
the sum of the digits that in track
would be an environment not but
regardless of these small complications
it turns out that this enough numbers
are missing a digit that regardless of
what did it is you're missing you can
still find x in them James I know you've
been really involved in work on the twin
prime conjecture and gaps between primes
and these are some of the most famous
glamorous problems in mathematics is
this a glamorous or important one or was
this almost like just a little Curia you
found along the way or is this got
significance so I find it a fun problem
to state but as stated it feels a bit
more like a recreational problem but
what really interests me is the
underlying techniques that go into the
proof the proof was actually quite
complicated and it was developing new
tools to try and get a handle on x this
was a fun application of these ideas but
maybe the long-term goal is that the
tools that are developed to get a handle
on x that work in this setting can maybe
one day be developed enough to get a
handle on primes in more complicated
settings like the twin prime conjecture
or something we've been working in base
10 so far for discussion because that's
the thing that's most familiar to us but
you can ask the same question in any
earth base the question gets easier as
the bases get bigger and so it also
follows that you can find infinitely
many Prime's that are missing
digit in any base bigger than equal to
ten and actually if you look at large
enough faces you can start avoiding more
than one number so yeah if you want to
avoid twos and sevens we guess that
should work in base ten but we don't
know how to prove it but we can prove it
in a big enough base
so maybe base 100 would work maybe it
needs to be a bit bigger I'm not totally
sure you can ask the same question as
well for smaller bases but as I said it
gets harder for smaller bases and so
base ten is at the moment right at the
threshold of our techniques it's quite
fortunate that the threshold is the most
natural one for us but one famous
conjecture is that there's infinitely
many MERS end times so these are Prime's
which of the form 2 to the N minus 1 and
these are interesting because often
these are very easy to test for whether
such numbers are prime or not so lots of
these records for the biggest primes are
all of the form 2 to the n minus 1 you
can think about this as a problem in
base 2 and then in base 2 any Mersenne
prime would just be the digit 1 repeated
so it would be a rep digit prime in base
2 or equivalently it'd be a prime that's
missing the digit 0 in base 2 so these
questions about times missing digits
actually relate to some of these really
long old sounding conjectures about
primes of special forms like there's n
times
James I've seen you give a lecture about
this before and now you've done a video
about it here with me and each time you
choose the number 7 you talk about how
many primes don't have a 7 why do you
choose 7 is your arbitrary example I
always seem to choose 7 and I don't
really know why to 7 any other number
would have been just as good I've
certainly read online that when people
are asked to choose a one digit number
they disproportionately to 7 and when
they choose two digit numbers they
disproportionately choose 37 I think so
there's supposed to be some
psychological thing about what seems
more random and more like a non
specifically chosen number but I guess
I'm always biased to choose a phone
number yeah I often like giving silly
questions when people ask me to choose a
random number I often choose one just to
be difficult because this is the sort of
thing that I find funny if you want to
find out more about professor maynard
including his favorite number check out
the latest edition of the numberphile
podcast I'll link to it on the screen
and down below and there'll also be
links to more videos with him so check
out those links as well